hi i'm camila ludington and i'm here
today with buzzfeed to answer
your burning questions spoilers beware
[Music]
do you remember what your audition was
like for jo and were you a fan of the
show before getting the role
first of all i was a huge fan of the
show i
had recently moved to los angeles when
the show aired and it was like
their show that i ran home to every
night to watch live
i was a massive fan of the show i geeked
out actually when i first got to set
and like ran around meredith's house and
did things i probably shouldn't have
done
like sitting on the couch when i
shouldn't have been sitting there i do
definitely remember that audition there
were two scenes there was one
scene that was just a big medical scene
with lots of medical dialogue like bps
dropping and all that kind of stuff
and then my second scene was a really
flirty
scene with another doctor do you have a
favorite joe moment
of any season of grace this one
i feel like might surprise people
because i changed them all the time but
i was thinking about this one the other
day i was working with jake who plays
levi
and i think one of my favorite scenes
for joe
is actually the scene where she wakes up
after having sex with him
and she creeps out of his mom's basement
and steps on his glasses and it's like
this really short scene
but it was something i'd actually
pitched to krista vernoff in the summer
to see come to fruition and with him and
he was so funny and the whole thing was
hysterical and
that is actually my favorite moment that
i can think of in
the season 17 premiere patrick dempsey
returned
which was incredible did you know about
his surprise appearance
when did you find out i did know about
his surprise appearance
i found out right before we started work
i actually thought that everyone knew
and then i read an interview that chris
has said that
not everyone knew and i don't know who
didn't know but i remember thinking it's
absolutely
going to get out there's no way that it
won't be spoiled and i'm shocked that it
didn't and i'm so happy because the fans
went
crazy also in the season 17 premiere joe
and jackson have a hilarious hilarious
sexy kiss people is a sexy kiss
where joe ends up crying what was it
like filming that scene with jesse
williams
so jesse and i have wanted to work
together for a really long time and so
we've been begging for scenes together
this is what we end up getting
we read it together at the table read
and we could not stop laughing it was
really funny and then when we actually
filmed the scene we also couldn't stop
laughing because
we improvised a little bit and it's just
really funny the writing was really
funny there was a moment where
like little things happened that made us
laugh like he hands me back the vodka
bottle that she had and it kind of hit
my hand away and it went all over my
face and then the yellow cat
were like no keep it in it's already so
awkward just keep it in
so we had a lot of fun filming that
scene joe arrived on grace during season
nine
is that any character that you wish joe
could have met from the earlier seasons
okay my husband knows this so it's okay
for me to say this but i have a huge
crush on kyle chandler i know he was
pink mist in the bomb episode so it
ended badly for him but i wish i'd had
one scene
just one scene with him one of the best
grey's anatomy episodes is silent all
these years
when joe helps a sexual assault survivor
what was it like filming that scene in
the hallway with all the women of gray
sloane
that episode was incredibly intense that
scene in particular was really emotional
and what i love about the scene that
some people know
not everybody knows is that the women
lining our hallway were not just
background doctors or
actors you know any actors that we had
on the show um we had a lot of people
in all different kind of departments on
the show a lot of women that wanted to
be part of the whole way of women so
there's people that were in editing or
some of our producers it was an
incredible scene it was very emotional
for everybody that day
so it turned out to be a fantastic very
powerful scene i think spoke to a lot of
people
joe's backstory has slowly been revealed
to us
over the years how much of it did you
know going in nothing
is the answer i did not know anything
when did you find out joe's real name
i didn't know anything the episode where
i
was helping a homeless man that's when i
was told that she had been homeless they
were like oh by the way you were
homeless and i was like oh good to know
crazy thing about being on grey's
anatomy is that you find out as the show
goes on so i didn't know that i've been
married before i didn't know
the abuse of relationship there was so
much that got revealed over the seasons
so i did not know anything going into it
really and i found out joe's name
when i read the script do you have a
favorite joe and alex moment on grey's
anatomy
it's way back in season nine but the the
time that they got drunk together at the
bar
was so funny in the hotel and then
stealing over and
key that is still one of my favorite
scenes with joe and alex all the way
back in the day what's your role people
would be surprised to find out you
auditioned for so many roles would i
audition for
i think i did i think i did tweet this
but i auditioned
for belle in once upon a time and i
really wanted it because who didn't want
to be a disney princess and i did i was
so sad when i got it and then i got
grazed very soon after so
it was meant to be season 17 has been
tackling the coronavirus pandemic what
has it been like bringing this important
storyline to life it's very strange
because usually there's a separation
between our real lives and then
obviously going
and shooting the show and what's really
bizarre about filming the pandemic is
that we're still in
it so we're wearing the mask to work
we're washing our hands we're doing all
the things we're supposed to be doing
and you know obviously it's very scary
and then we get to work and we're
playing it out as
front line workers so it's a very
intense season
and you know it's it looks very
different on set we all have to stay six
feet apart
and you know abc and disney are taking
all the precautions necessary to keep us
all safe
but i think it's really important and i
i can tell from the fan reaction that
people are really
happy actually that we're that we're
giving this storyline this season
is there a grey's enemy cast group chat
or who do you talk to the most when
you're not
on set jessie captures one of my best
friends who plays arizona and she'll
always be part of gray so that will be
my answer
i text jake all the time and there's
no cast group chat there should be but i
think that we're all on individual chats
with each other
who is your dream gray's anatomy guesta
taylor swift i know she loves the show i
feel like she should just do
one episode i don't i don't know how it
would happen as a patient or she's a
doctor
but i think that she deserves to come on
and finally what tv show are you
currently obsessed with
okay guys i have just started i know i'm
late but the boys i don't know if you
guys are watching it it is
so good i want to be a member of the
seven
so bad whether i'm good or evil it's
amazing
i've binged it i actually have just one
episode to go which is the finale of
season two but it's incredible
i need to be part of that fandom too
thank you buzzfeed so much for having me
it was a pleasure answering all of your
fan questions do not forget to watch
grey's anatomy on abc
9 pm thursday nights
you